difficile de croire qu'il s'agit de
toile d'ado créé en 1999 sous
l'impulsion des jeunes conseillers
municipaux le salon imagine à la maison
de Coville à voisin le Bretonneux permet
aux vcinois d'exposer leurs création 33
artistes âgés de 8 à 18 ans participe
cette année au Salon le dessin c'est pas
fait pour rester dans un coin dans un
tiroir c'est fait pour montrer aux
autres pour partager et puis aussi c'est
peut-être une manière de enfin nous de
nous encourager à continuer à dessiner
ça ça nous donne un but précis et puis
même peut-être que d'autres gens qui ça
peut inspirer d'autres gens à
dessiner nouveauté cette année le salon
est ouvert aux apprentis photographes au
fil des éditions le public peut
apercevoir l'évolution des artistes
présents depuis plusieurs fois il a
révélé des jeunes talents il y a des
œuvres qui marquent les esprits il y a
des artistes aussi qui marquent les
esprits aujourd'hui on me parle encore
d'artistes qui ont exposé
dans les premiers salons imagine
aujourd'hui on cite encore leur nom on a
essayé de les faire exposer chez les
adultes donc ilils ont tenté
l'expérience mais aujourd'hui on me cite
encore des personnes comme Édouard
Lefèvre qui avaient exposé ainsi que
d'autres artistes les visiteurs
peuventlire leur coup de cœur selon les
catégories d'âge la remise des prix se
déroulera ce samedi à
16h